LIZ NOLAN: I like
to solve problems.
And I think I have a fascination
with the natural world.
And those merge well in
the context of science.
Not all bacteria are harmful.
And in fact, if you
consider a person
on a cell-per-cell basis,
there are more bacterial cells
in us or on us than are
eukaryotic or human cells.
Many bacteria help us out, maybe
with the digestion of food.
But other types of bacteria
have the propensity
to invade tissues
or produce toxins.
And so if their populations
get out of check,
they make us sick.
Just like humans or any
animal, bacteria need food.
In my lab, we're particularly
interested in metal ions.
And you might not think of
metal ions as being food,
but they are essential
nutrients for all organisms.
Bacteria seeking to
colonize or survive
within the host
environment need methods
to acquire certain metals.
We respond first by using
our innate immune response.
MEGAN BROPHY: So
it's kind of gross,
but you can see some protein.
And then you have fat
on top where it's shiny.
I work with a human protein
called calprotectin.
And it's secreted in response
to bacterial infection.
And when it encounters
these bacteria,
it chelates, so it grabs
onto zinc and manganese
in the environment and
starves the bacteria.
LIZ NOLAN: So zinc is
an essential nutrient.
And the general idea is
that calprotectin is somehow
acting as a sponge.
In my lab, we over-express
and purify calprotectin
or [? mutants ?] where
we have systematically
changed an amino acid we think
is important for calprotectin's
mechanism and then utilize
this purified protein
in a suite of studies.
We can come to conclusions about
where the metal binds and how.
We can also do experiments
called titrations
that allow us to determine
how tightly the metal
binds to a particular site and
also what the selectivity is--
so does calprotectin
have a preference?
Does it prefer to bind
zinc over manganese,
over some other
metal ion or not?
In high school, I didn't like
my chemistry class very much.
And that motivated me to
take chemistry first thing
in college.
And I loved it.
I liked that it
was quantitative.
And I felt it overlapped
well with courses
I took in biology and geology.
And when I ultimately
decided on a major,
I found chemistry the
most appealing because
of its broad
applicability and ability
to bring a molecular-level
understanding
to very complex questions.
[MUSIC PLAYING]